[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA BANDURA: Hello everyone.
My name is Laura Bandura, and
I'm a research geophysicist
at Chevron.
Some of you may remember that
I was on stage at Google Next
last July.
Back then, I talked about
how to make sense out of way
too much data.
We were using Google
Cloud's AutoML Vision
API to analyze the
content of thousands
of geoscience documents and
to make them searchable.
My goal then was to describe
how we could quickly
access and utilize the work
documented by thousands
of Chevron employees
in the form of field
reports, seismic recordings,
core samples, lab
analyses, environmental
studies, and much more.
With Google Cloud, we got it
in one place, digitized it,
and through the power
of machine learning
gave this data new life.
Today, I want to tell
you how far we've
come with that
project and how we've
added tools to do something
far more valuable--
creating a new way of
consuming information
by a rich and diverse
team of people
and acting faster to
achieve our business goals.
The energy business literally
powers the modern world.
For someone like me,
part of the excitement
is understanding how we
use geology and geophysics
to understand the
subsurface of the Earth.
In my work, we use
seismic waves to probe
the subsurface geology.
Those measurements are then
used to create detailed pictures
of what the Earth looked
like deep into the past
and also to help us determine
where oil and gas are located.
Here we show an example of a
modern river system containing
channel features that have
similar dimensions and patterns
to features that
we tried to find
in the subsurface
for exploration.
And one of these
examples is this image
of a submarine
canyon system that we
found within seismic data.
But the excitement
doesn't stop there.
The next step is to connect our
interpretations of these images
to the value chain and
to ultimately impact
how we produce oil and gas.
For an integrated energy
company like Chevron
that means working with
multiple teams globally
that include research
scientists, engineers,
and analysts.
Some of us are working in
offices interpreting data,
and others are out in the
field conducting operations.
Communicating with our peers
across geographic and language
boundaries and across
subject matter domains
is nothing new to Chevron.
In fact, we've done this
very well for over a century.
Over time however,
information can become siloed.
What if we could create
some common digital spaces
where all teams
could look at all
of the available
information to support
the work that they are doing?
What if all of
Chevron's experts could
have the best data available
at all times, regardless
of where they are
located or what
their technical specialty is?
How would we organize
something like that?
And the answer is to take
things back to basics.
And for us, that is the
earth and to build it up
in a whole new way.
On Google Cloud,
we've created a system
that digitizes text, tables, and
images, all sorts of notations
and data readings.
We've made everything
searchable through metadata that
was automatically generated.
With AutoML, we utilize custom
geologic labels to tag images
and use knowledge graphs
to summarize field reports.
With natural language
processing and translation,
we created an enormous index
of our data and documents
that is now searchable
in any language.
This means that
data from years ago
can be combined with
more recent findings
or matched against
technology improvements
that we've made in field
development planning and safety
or even in well completions,
giving new life to work
that took place many years ago.
Where physical and geographical
data are concerned,
Google Earth is the key
technology for visualization.
We can take the surface
view of the earth
and then expand it to
create a view of its
below surface features,
as well as we know them
from decades of our work in
exploration and production,
populating it with
information like seismic data
and well logs that
describe transitions
between geologic layers.
We can add publicly
available information
about surrounding geologies
and industry activities,
developing still richer
ways of seeing our data
with new understanding.
And this is really
literally decades
of human work seen in
the context of millions
of years of geology.
And this is really just
the beginning for us.
We have new ways of seeing and
using legacy and modern data
and linking it with
real-time business processes
happening within Chevron
around the globe each day
from earth science to
facilities engineering,
to environment and
safety, and beyond.
Through our collaboration
with Google,
we have developed
a framework that
enables us to do more
together, connecting
our technical experts to
our data and to each other.
And that's really made possible
by what our hosts today
are calling One Google.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]